it's so cool it's crazy I remember when
I was 14 I was in the kitchen with my
mom and she was going through Forbes and
I was like I'm gonna be there one day I
look around and I see some of the
amazing individuals who are changing the
world and I honestly feel very excited
to be here we're leaving at 30 under 30
means that I am a trailblazer I take
risks I don't take no for an answer
I turn all my nose into guesses I've
never felt more privileged to be in the
company of a lot of young startups and a
lot of young people who have the
ambition and the confidence to really
change things in our system I'm bursting
at the seams with pride it's sort of
kind of embarrassing to admit that
because you know I'm just to be like the
cool calm collected entrepreneurs I mean
look at I've got like a background
behind me that's you know this isn't
just like a random wall this is the real
deal and that's just an amazing
situation of being I'm so proud to be
here I think that to be recognized for
that and interview and for other people
who asked them or backgrounds to be able
see me and see what they can do to is I
think the best thing in the world being
a 30 under 30 obviously this is just a
huge honor and it's amazing and it's
just so cool but it also just brings me
to the mind that I have a lot more that
I want to do I know it's kind of
bittersweet for me right I'm sort of
like okay this is nice
Dolch for a little bit and okay now
we're back back to the mission right
like don't don't let it sort of distract
you